FEMALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we will discuss the
inverse hyperbolic functions
and, with this lecture, finish
our block on the logarithmic
exponential and hyperbolic
functions.
And what we're going to find is
that much of what we have
to say today is simply a
specific application to a
special function of the same
theory that we were talking
about in general before.
Recall that we can always talk
about an inverse function if
the original function is
a one-to-one function.
For example, to introduce
today's topic, suppose we take
the function 'y' equals
hyperbolic sine 'x'.
'y' equals 'sinh x'.
Well, as we saw last time,
the graph of 'y'
equals 'sinh x' is this.
And we can see in a glance
that this clearly is a
one-to-one function.
In fact, the derivative
of sinh is cosh.
And as we've seen also
last time, the cosh
can never be negative.
In fact, the cosh can't
be less than one.
So here is a curve that's
always rising--
and, in fact, in general
rising quite steeply.
In any event, we can therefore
talk about the inverse
hyperbolic sine.
All right?
And how do we get the inverse
function in general?
Well we've always seen that to
invert a function, all we have
to do is to reflect the original
graph with respect to
the line, 'y' equals 'x'.
Or, again, in more slow motion,
we rotate through 90
degrees and then flip
the graph over.
And, in any event, whichever way
you want to look at this
thing, we obtain that the
graph 'y' equals inverse
hyperbolic sine 'x' is this
particular curve over here.
This is the graph of the inverse
hyperbolic sine.
Now, again, what was the main
issue or the main property of
inverse functions?
The idea was that once we knew
the original function, we
could, by a change in emphasis,
study the inverse function.
Well, by way of illustration,
let's suppose we take the
functional relationship 'y'
equals inverse hyperbolic sine
'x' and we say, let's
find the 'ydx'.
Recall that what we know how to
do, is how to differentiate
the hyperbolic sine.
Consequently, given that y
equals the inverse hyperbolic
sine 'x', we simply switch the
emphasis and say, this is the
same as saying that 'x'
equals 'sinh y'.
And if 'x' equal 'sinh y',
we already know that the
derivative of 'x' with respect
to 'y' is 'cosh y'.
And since the derivative of 'y'
with respect to 'x' is the
reciprocal of the derivative of
'x' with respect to 'y', we
can conclude from this that the
'ydx' is '1 over cosh y'.
In a certain manner
of speaking, we're
all finished now.
We have found that the
derivative off inverse 'sinh
x' is '1 over cosh y'.
The only problem is, is as we've
said many times also
before that if 'y' is given as
a function of 'x', we would
like the 'ydx' expressed
in terms of 'x'.
Or, to put it in still different
words, usually when
you're given an expression like
the 'ydx', you're asked
to evaluate this when 'x' is
some particular value, not
when 'y' is some particular
value.
At any rate, we do much the same
here as we did with the
inverse circular
trig functions.
Namely, having arrived at '1
over cosh y' and remembering
that the relationship that ties
in 'x' and 'y' is at 'x'
equals 'sinh y', we invoke the
fundamental identity that
'cosh squared y' minus 'sinh
squared y' is 1.
From which we can conclude
that 'cosh y'--
and here we have to be a
little bit careful--
if we solve this algebraically
we find that 'cosh y' is plus
or minus the square root of
'1 plus 'sinh squared y''.
But recalling the cosh could
never be negative, it means
that for this particular
problem, the minus
sign does not apply.
In other words, since cosh has
to be at least as big one, you
see, that 'cosh y' is plus the
square root of '1 plus 'sinh
squared y''.
Now keep in mind why we
went to this identity
in the first place.
The reason we went to this
identity in the first place,
is if we come back to the
beginning of our problem we
see that we had that 'x'
is equal to 'sinh y'.
In other words, down here now,
all we do is replace 'sinh y'
by a synonym, namely 'x'.
And we arrive at the fact that
'cosh y' is the square root of
'1 plus 'x squared''.
Therefore, since 'dy/dx' is the
reciprocal of 'cosh y',
the derivative of 'y' with
respect to 'x' is '1 over the
'square root of '1 plus
'x squared'''.
And this is summarized in
our last step over here.
In other words, the derivative
of the inverse hyperbolic sine
of 'x' with respect to 'x' is '1
over the 'square root of '1
plus 'x squared'''.
Now, you see, the first thing I
want to point out here is to
observe that without worrying
about what's important about
this result, is to observe
again that we obtain this
information virtually free of
charge by knowing the calculus
of the regular hyperbolic
functions.
You see, this result
was obtained
without any new knowledge.
The other thing I'd like to
point out here is somewhat
more subtle.
And we also mentioned this in
the same context, but from a
different point of view, when
we dealt with the inverse
circular functions.
Many people will say things
like, who needs the inverse
hyperbolic functions?
How many times am I going to be
confronted with having to
work with inverse hyperbolic
functions?
And the interesting point that's
typified by this result
is that if we now invert
this emphasis--
in other words, if we now
read this equation
from right to left--
observe that if you start with
the function '1 over the
'square root of '1 plus
'x squared''''--
which is hardly a hyperbolic
function, this is a fairly
straightforward algebraic
function--
notice that the inverse
derivative leads to an inverse
hyperbolic sine.
In other words, stated from a
different perspective and
using our language of the
indefinite integral, notice
that what we have here is that
the indefinite integral 'dx'
over the 'square root of '1 plus
'x squared''' is inverse
hyperbolic sine 'x'
plus a constant.
Now what does this mean,
say, geometrically?
Suppose we take the curve 'y'
equals '1 over the 'square
root of '1 plus 'x squared'''.
Without beating this thing to
death, it should be fairly
straightforward at this stage of
the game that the graph of
this function can be obtained,
and it looks
something like this.
In fact, intuitively notice that
'y' will be maximum when
my denominator is smallest.
My denominator is smallest
when 'x' is zero.
So the maximum value of 'y'
occurs when 'x' is 0, at which
case, 'y' is 1.
Also, if I replace 'x'
by minus 'x', I
don't change the function.
And therefore the graph--
it's an even function--
the graph is symmetric
with respect to
the y-axis, et cetera.
At any rate, I have a
picture like this.
And now suppose I want to find
the area of the region 'R',
where 'R' is bounded above by
this curve, below by the
x-axis, on the left by the
y-axis, and on the right by
the line 'x' equals 't'.
The area of the region 'R',
which is a function of 't', is
given by what?
The definite integral from 0 to
't', 'dx' over the 'square
root of '1 plus 'x squared'''.
The point is I could, as we
talked about in the previous
block, try to evaluate this as
the limit of a sum-- in other
words, an infinite sum--
and go through all sorts of work
to try to do this thing.
But the first fundamental
theorem tells us in this
particular case that this
particular area just turns out
to be the inverse hyperbolic
sine of 't'.
Notice that a non-trigonometric
region has
as its answer an inverse
hyperbolic
trigonometric function.
Or, if you want this thing
more specifically, for
example, notice that if you want
the area of this region
from 0 to 1, the answer to this
problem would have just
been the inverse hyperbolic
sine of 1.
In other words, 'e to the
1' minus 'e to the
minus 1' over 2.
Notice how 'e' sneaks into
a problem which basically
doesn't seem to have any
relationship to 'e'.
By the way-- as a very
brief aside--
for what it's worth, it's rather
interesting to observe
that this last equation that
we've written down gives a
rather interesting definition of
the inverse hyperbolic sine
without having to refer to
a hyperbola or anything
trigonometric.
In other words, notice that the
inverse hyperbolic sine
can be defined as an integral,
which is what we've really
done over here.
But again, that's
just an aside.
The main point that I wanted us
to get a hold of over here
was the fact that you solve
non-hyperbolic functions
conveniently if we
have mastered
the hyperbolic functions.
Well, at any rate, here's
another interesting question
that comes up.
And I thought that we should
mention this, also.
Notice that we arrived at
this result by doing
the thing in reverse.
You'll recall that we started
with 'y' equals inverse
hyperbolic sine 'x' and show
the derivative of that
function was '1 over the 'square
root of '1 plus 'x
squared'''.
An interesting question might
have been, what if we had
started with the integral being
given and we hadn't have
differentiated the inverse
hyperbolic sine?
How could we have got
from here to the
inverse hyperbolic sine?
And I thought I would mention
this because there may be some
confusion, especially if you've
taken to heart certain
advice that I gave you earlier
when we dealt with the inverse
circular functions.
Remember I told you that
whenever you see something
like the sum of two squares, to
think of a right triangle?
In other words, if you have the
square root of '1 plus 'x
squared'', it seems to me that
the triangle that suggests
itself is something like this.
In other words, if I call this
side 'x', I call this side 1,
and this the square root of '1
plus 'x squared'', it would
seem to me that I could make
a circular trigonometric
substitution over here.
In fact, what seems to dictate
itself over here, is to make
the substitution, let
tan theta equal 'x'.
Now if I let tan theta equal
'x', watch what happens here.
I get 'secant squared theta 'd
theta'' equals 'dx', taking
the differential
of both sides.
I also get, looking at my
reference triangle, that the
square root of '1 plus 'x
squared'' is secant theta.
See, this over this
is secant theta.
At any rate, then, making the
substitution in here,
replacing 'dx' by 'secant
squared theta 'd theta'', and
the square root of '1 plus 'x
squared'' by secant theta, I
wind up with integral of 'secant
theta 'd theta''.
Now you see what I've done here,
is I have successfully
transformed an integral
in terms of 'x' into
one in terms of theta.
But without belaboring this
point, it turns out that at
this stage of the game, we do
not know how to exhibit a
function whose derivative
with respect to
theta is secant theta.
In other words, we've made the
substitution but we wind up
with an integral that's just as
tough to handle as the one
that we started with.
You see, in this case, trying
to make a circular
trigonometric substitution
wouldn't have
helped us very much.
What I'd like to show you is,
again, an interesting
connection between the circular
functions and the
hyperbolic functions.
Namely, when we did this
particular thing over here
using our reference triangle,
what was the reference
triangle really taking
the place of?
Notice that if we let 'x' equal
tan theta, certainly '1
plus 'x squared'' is 1 plus
tan squared theta.
But there is a trigonometric
identity that says 1 plus tan
squared theta is secant
squared theta.
I think the usual way that's
given is that secant squared
theta minus tan squared
theta is 1.
This is the result
that we used.
We didn't really use the
triangle other than to get
this result more visually.
The point is, is there a
hyperbolic function that has
the same format?
Is there a hyperbolic identity
which says that the difference
of two squares is one?
The answer is, well remember our
basic hyperbolic identity
is the cosh squared theta minus
sinh squared theta is 1.
Structurally, notice that sinh
theta does for the hyperbolic
functions what tan theta does
for the circular functions.
See the common structure,
here?
We're going to reinforce this
in the next block by doing
problems like this again.
But for the time being, I
thought I would like to point
this thing out to you.
What the approach is, is that
when you try a circular
function substitution and it
doesn't give you the answer
that you want-- meaning that you
wind up with an integral
that's just as tough to handle
as the original one--
you look for the corresponding
hyperbolic function.
What hyperbolic function plays
to the hyperbolic identity the
same role that this
trigonometric function play to
the circular identity?
In this case, we replace tan
theta by sinh theta.
Instead of making the
substitution 'x' equals
tangent theta, we make
the substitution
'x' equals sinh theta.
And now watch what happens as
we work this thing quite
mechanically.
The differential of sinh theta
is 'cosh theta 'd theta''.
And the square root of '1 plus
'x squared'' is the square
root of 1 plus sin
squared theta.
But notice that because
of the relationship
between sinh and cosh--
that's how we rig this thing,
that's why we chose 'x' to be
sinh theta--
notice that the square root of
1 plus sinh squared theta is
just cosh theta.
And therefore, when we now
substitute for the 'dx' over
the square root of '1 plus 'x
squared'', we get what?
For 'dx' we have 'cosh
theta 'd theta''.
For the square root of
'1 plus 'x squared''
we have cosh theta.
'Cosh theta 'd theta'' over cosh
theta is just 'd theta'.
And now we see the answer is,
quite simply, theta plus 'c'.
But what was theta?
Since sinh theta was 'x',
theta was inverse
hyperbolic sine 'x'.
And, you see, this is a
technique whereby starting
with the integral 'dx' over the
'square root of '1 plus 'x
squared''', we can show that
we must have started with
inverse sinh.
At any rate, this will be
reinforced in homework
problems, it will be reinforced
in the next block
when we talk about techniques
of integration.
But I just wanted to again
show the similarity, the
things in common, between the
hyperbolic functions and the
circular functions and how
they're intertwined.
Let's make a few more comments
while we're at it.
You know, we mentioned that the
hyperbolic functions were
really combinations of
exponential functions.
Remember, 'cosh x' was ''e to
the x' plus 'e to the minus
x'' over 2, et cetera.
So somehow or other, if the
hyperbolic functions can be
expressed in terms of
exponentials, it would seem
that the inverse hyperbolic
functions should be
expressible in terms of the
inverse of exponentials--
namely, in terms
of logarithms.
And so I thought that I would
try to go through some of
these finer points with you.
And, for example, ask the
following question.
Given that 'y' equals inverse
'sinh x', is there a way of
writing this in terms of
something that uses our
natural logarithms?
Another reason being, what?
That if we've already learned
natural logs and exponentials,
it would seem that whenever we
can reduce unfamiliar names to
more familiar ones,
psychologically we feel much
more at home in dealing
with the concepts.
In other words, one might feel
strange working with inverse
hyperbolic sine because he
hasn't seen that very much.
But if he's used to seeing
logarithms, that wouldn't seem
quite as strange.
At any rate, let's see how
one could proceed here.
Starting out with 'y' equals
inverse 'sinh x', notice that
by the property, the basic
definition of inverse
functions, I can now write
that 'x' equals 'sinh y'.
Now, for obvious reasons,
since I want to get the
inverse of exponentials in here,
it would seem to me that
I should express 'sinh y' in
terms of exponentials.
And going again back to basic
definitions, 'sinh y' is ''e
to the y' minus 'e to the
minus y'' over 2.
In other words, in terms of
exponentials, 'x' is equal to
''e to the y' minus 'e to
the minus y'' over 2.
If I now cross multiply, I get
that '2x' is equal to 'e to
the y' minus--
now notice that 'e to the minus
y' is just '1 over 'e to
the y'', so I wind up now with
this particular equation.
And multiplying through by 'e to
the y', to clear fractions
in my denominator, to clear
my denominators, I
wind up with what?
'e to the 2y' minus ''2x 'e
to the y'' - 1' equals 0.
And if I now recall that 'e to
the 2y' is the square of 'e to
the y', observe that what I
now have is a quadratic
equation in 'e to the y'.
I have a quadratic equation
in 'e to the y'.
Now, since I have a quadratic
equation in 'e to the y', I
can use the quadratic formula
to solve for 'e to the y'.
If I do this I get what?
Remember how this thing works.
I take the coefficient of this
term minus that, that's '2x'
plus or minus the square root of
this squared minus 4 times
this times the coefficient
of 'e to the y' squared.
Leaving the details as being
fairly obvious, 'e to the y'
is '2x' plus or minus the square
root of ''4x' squared'
plus 4 all over 2.
And noticing now that the 4 can
be factored out here as a
2, and that I can cancel a 2,
then from both the numerator
and denominator, I wind up with
'e to the y' is 'x' plus
or minus the square root
of 'x squared' plus 1.
The point to keep in mind, now,
is remember that in terms
of exponentials, 'e to the
y' can never be negative.
Observe that the square root
of 'x squared plus 1' is
bigger than 'x' in magnitude,
you see.
See, 'x' would be just
the positive
square root of 'x squared'.
So the positive square root of
'x squared plus 1' is bigger
than 'x' in magnitude.
Consequently, if I use the minus
sign here, I'd be taking
away more than what I had.
That would make my answer
negative, which would be a
contradiction, since 'e to
the y' can't be negative.
Again, in terms of this
particular problem, the minus
root, the minus sign
here is extraneous.
And we therefore wind
up with what?
'e to the y' is 'x' plus
the square root of 'x
squared plus 1'.
Therefore 'y' itself is the
'log of x' plus the square
root of 'x squared plus 1' to
the base 'e', which we've
already seen is called
the natural log.
Going back now, say, from the
first step to the last, I
guess we can now fill in what's
really happened here.
A synonym for the inverse 'sinh
x' is the natural log of
'x' plus the square root
of 'x squared plus 1'.
So notice that we can study the
inverse sinh, for example,
in terms of a suitably
chosen natural log.
And of course there are many
more examples that we could
use along these lines.
But again, I think that with
the previous explanation,
coupled with the fact that there
will be ample exercises
in the like, I think the message
has become clear as
far as the inverse hyperbolic
sine is concerned.
What I would like to do now is
to turn to another facet of
inverse functions, something
that involves principal values
the same as it did with the
circular functions.
We wind up with the same problem
as before when we come
to the idea that, technically
speaking, you cannot talk
about an inverse function unless
the original function
is one-to-one.
And so therefore, when one
talks about the inverse
hyperbolic cosine, one is in a
way looking for trouble if one
doesn't keep his eye
on exactly what's
going on around here.
Namely, if we look at the graph
'y' equals hyperbolic
cosine 'x', observe that whereas
the function is single
valued, it is not one-to-one.
In fact, there is a zero
derivative at this point here,
which leads us to believe that
maybe what we should have done
was to have broken this curve
down into the union of two
one-to-one functions.
Let me call this curve 'y'
equals 'c1 of x' and let me
call this branch here 'y'
equals 'c2 of x'.
Notice that both 'c1
of x' and 'c2 of x'
are one-to-one functions.
In fact, let's write this
more formally using the
picture as a guide.
Let's do the following
analytically.
Let's say this.
Define 'c sub 1 of x' to be
'cosh x', provided that 'x' is
at least as big as 0.
Again, I mentioned this with the
circular functions, let me
reinforce this again.
To define a function, it's not
enough to tell the rule.
You must also tell the domain.
Notice that 'c1' is not the
same as cosh, because the
domain of cosh is all
real numbers.
The domain of 'c1' is just
the non-negative reals.
At any rate, I define 'c1' to
be 'cosh x', where 'x' is at
least as big as 0.
I define 'c2 of x' to be
'cosh x', where 'x' is
no bigger than 0.
In other words, these two
functions are different,
because even though the
functional relations are the
same, the domains
are different.
The interesting point is what?
That 'cosh x' is the union
of 'c1' and 'c2'.
But the important point is that
both 'c1' and 'c2' are
one-to-one.
And because they
are one-to-one,
their inverses exist.
In other words, I can talk
meaningfully about 'c1
inverse' and 'c2 inverse'.
In fact, pictorially,
what I have is this.
See, if I take the curve 'y'
equals 'cosh x' and reflect it
about the 45 degree line, this
is the curve that I get.
You see, it's a double
value curve.
All I'm saying is if we look at
'y' equals 'c1x', which is
a one-to-one function, its
inverse is 'c1 inverse x',
which is this piece over here.
And if, on the other hand, we
look at 'y' equals 'c2x',
that's this branch over here,
its inverse is this.
You see, notice that these two
pieces are symmetric with
respect to the line 'y' equals
'x', and these two pieces are
symmetric with respect to
the line 'y' equals 'x'.
As long as we break this down
into the union of two pieces,
we can talk about inverse
functions.
Now you see, the interesting
point is that what most
authors traditionally refer to
as the inverse hyperbolic
cosine of 'x' is really what
we call 'c1 inverse of x'.
In other words, the definition
'y' equals inverse hyperbolic
cosine 'x' is 'x'
equals cosh 'y'.
And this is very important,
and 'y' is at
least as big as 0.
Notice that the domain of 'cosh
inverse x' is really 'x'
has to be at least
as big as one.
But that's not the important
point here.
What I do want to see over here
is that when you put this
restriction on, instead if you
left this restriction out,
there would be no inverse
function here.
I'll come back to that
in a moment.
Let me just reinforce what we've
talked about before, and
let's find the derivative
of 'inverse cosh x'.
In other words, let's find
'dy/dx', if 'y' equals
'inverse cosh x'.
Well again, what is the
definition, 'y' equals
'inverse cosh x'?
It means 'x' equals cosh y',
where 'y' is positive.
OK.
If 'x' equals 'cosh y',
'dx/dy' is 'sinh y'.
And we'll keep track of the
fact that 'y' is positive.
Actually, 'y' is non-negative.
Therefore the reciprocal of
'dx/dy' will be 'dy/dx'.
In other words, 'dy/dx'
is '1 over sinh y'.
And this would be a correct
answer, except, as usual, we
would like to be able to express
'dy/dx' for a given
value of 'x'.
What we do now is, remembering
that 'x' is 'cosh y', we
invoke the identity again.
'Cosh squared y' minus 'sinh
squared y' is one.
From which we can solve and find
that 'sinh y' is plus or
minus the 'square root of
'x squared minus 1'.
And by the way, I'm not
going to remove the
extraneous sign here.
Because in a certain manner
of speaking, it is only
extraneous because we are
imposing the condition that
'y' is positive.
See, in other words, once we
assume that y' is positive--
remember that 'sinh y' is
positive for positive values
of 'y', and negative for
negative values of 'y'--
consequently, the assumption
that 'y' is positive forces us
to accept the fact that
'sinh y' is positive.
And that's what forces us, in
terms of the restriction that
we imposed the fact that y has
to be at least as big as 0,
why we can get rid of
the minus sign here.
And so we wind up with what?
'Sinh y' is positive 'square
root of 'cosh squared
y' minus 1''.
But 'cosh y' is 'x'
in this problem.
In other words, 'sinh y', in
this problem, is the positive
square root of 'x squared
minus 1'.
By the way, don't
be nervous here.
You might say, couldn't
this be imaginary?
In other words, what happens if
'x squared' is less than 1?
Remember, 'x' is at
least as big as 1.
So this thing here in
the square root sign
can never be negative.
But at any rate, what we now
wind up with is that the
derivative of 'inverse cosh x',
with respect to 'x', is '1
over the 'square root of ''x
squared' minus 1'''.
Now again, there's no law that
says that a person couldn't
have been on the negative
branch of this curve.
In other words, if all you mean
by inverse cosh is the
inverse of cosh with no
restriction to branch, what
we've really proven is this.
And let me summarize on
this particular point.
What we've really
proven is this.
That the derivative of 'c1'
inverse is '1 over the 'square
root of ''x squared'
minus 1'''.
The derivative of 'c2' inverse
is '1 over minus the 'square
root of ''x squared'
minus 1'''.
I've taken the liberty of
putting the minus down with
the square root sign, rather
than with the fraction itself,
to emphasize the fact that
which of the two signs we
choose depends on whether we're
looking at the branch
for which 'y' is above the
x-axis, or the branch which
'y' is below the x-axis.
In other words, what we don't
want to happen here is for
people to lose track of the fact
that all we have done is
made a convention so we can
talk about one-to-one
functions and inverse functions
more meaningfully.
But you can be on either of
these particular branches.
In any event, this does complete
our discussion of the
hyperbolic functions.
And we will now turn
our attention to
utilizing these results.
We will learn some techniques of
integration, and the like.
But at any rate, until
next time, goodbye.
MALE SPEAKER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.